[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday October
22nd and today we're going to have a
special extra nerdy edition of
Brotherhood 2.0 which is saying
something because you know usually we're
fairly nerdy but today I'm going all out
Hank as I said it's October 22nd which
according to some people is the six
thousand and twelfth birthday of the
universe Hank in the 17th century
Archbishop James Ussher calculated that
according to the Bible the world was
created in 4004 BC on October 22nd just
after nightfall that is some precise
calculation Hank now as it happens of
course in addition to being precise it's
also idiotic but Hank you can't really
blame James Ussher for having a bad idea
I mean he lived in the 17th century when
a lot of people had a lot of bad ideas
like for example hey what do you think
we should do with all these people who
aren't from Europe I don't know
enslave them and also hey why do you
think everybody keeps dying of smallpox
I don't know I've been wondering about
that too hey do you mind if I coughed
directly into your mouth no be my guest
go right ahead
Hank the amazing thing about uh sure
chronology is that unlike theories about
smallpox and colonialization rushers
chronology has survived pretty well
there are still a lot of people who
believe that the earth is about six
thousand years old and all those
so-called young earth creationists are
inspired by Usher's original chronology
which frankly strikes me as ludicrous
anyway Hank aside from being a gigantic
nerd and spending the weekend reading
about James Ussher and his chronology
I've been working a lot my wonderful
editor at Dutton Julie Strauss Gables
sent me back the edits for Paper Towns
look Hank Julie is so organized that she
color-coded all the post-its in the
manuscript oh and speaking of Paper
Towns Hank if I ever mentioned to you
that the phrase Paper Towns anagrams -
pants power I might have mentioned that
before sometimes I can't remember what I
have and have not mentioned on
Brotherhood 2.0 because you know we've
been making these videos every weekday
for ten months
but anyway Paper Towns anagrams - pants
power which i think is totally awesome
Paper Towns also enter grams - prawn
pesto which sounds delicious
anyway Hank in other news that I wanted
to share with you and the nerdfighters
I'm also working on another book with my
friends Maureen 13 little blue envelopes
Johnson and Lauren
ttyl miracle that book is called let it
snow which anagrams - stolen wit did
someone steal my wit
it also antah grams - the motto of the
National Association of poor spelling
weavers we knit lots o anagram jokes
penc
they are truly the champagne of nerd
humor oh and speaking of champagne in
the 17th century Hank
know that it was in ER around the Year
1670 that a monk named Dom Perignon
invented champagne Hank it said that
when Dom Perignon had his first sip of
champagne he called out to another monk
come quickly I am tasting the Stars I'll
drink to that
Hank I'll see you tomorrow pants power